it's a friday night at fenway and natal
valde is on the bump for the red sox as
they go up against the indians already
eight pitches deep into this plate
appearance and another three twos caught
on and missed and that is the slider
because they average well over five and
a half a game
trying to go the other way it's gonna be
up and it is off the green monster is
that something and jose's into second
base with a two-out double
he gave him something uh up and away and
jose just slapped it the other way
of all the deals and he's stuck with a
fastball and he strikes out reyes in
case two in a scoreless first well it's
quattro night in boston tonight he will
be the indian starting pitcher cal 42
nine three era the pitch is swung on
driven to center field indeed back goes
straw looking up and this ball is gone
deep into the bleachers to the right of
the flagpole under the camera position
and the red sox lead at one nothing kyle
schwarber with the lead-off home run and
it was a no-doubter
swing and a miss down goes jd martinez
hunter renfro retired and it brings up
kevin plawecki
he yanks a bullet to left and out of the
ballpark
a frozen rope for kevin plewecki and a
solo shot makes it two nothing nice job
keeping the hands inside so he's not
pulling it foul call this the ride of
the founding fathers this is kevin
kliwecki getting in with jason veretech
i tell you what one ticket two
passengers right there that's incredible
there's so much i love about that
oh one swinging a drive port the gap in
right center field and this ball is
going to hit on the track one hop the
bullpen wall and jack lopez is in the
second base with a double his first
major league head and look at alex cora
i mean i'm not sure he's been happier
about anything all year
what a really cool moment for a kid and
his manager he's two balls and two
strikes on austin hedges cleveland's
catcher out of the eighth spot
laden off in the third out of all the
deals
got him
that's nasty
1-2 pitch
got him swinging avaldi has back-to-back
case and four total his first time
through the lineup
0-2
got him swinging with 96 and three
strikeouts in the third for ivaldi third
inning back to the top of the order kyle
schwarber
swung through a fastball and a good one
from count quantrill that's his second
strikeout one down here in the third lot
of strikeouts in that great month of
august for quattro as divers grounds one
up the middle into center field of base
hit and a one out knock for raphael
debra's in the third
pulled into left field to base set
debra sprints around second as mercado
collects and it's back-to-back knox for
the red sox here in the third
went back to that chain job struck him
out with a change up in off the plate he
sets he fires
and it's grounded toward third fielded
on the glove side ramirez to second for
the ending ending force what a job by
cal cuantro bases loaded one out red sox
don't score but it's been tough sledding
so far tonight jose ramirez the only hit
of the game and avali with the 2-1
offering
ramirez got all of that one deep right
field renfrow's out of room it's out of
here
the indians are on the board and they
have homework in 17 straight games
number 32 on the season for jose ramirez
and it's a 2-1 ball game
of all these one two
got em swinging
a half dozen caves now for native aldi
wow
full mix on display from vivaldi that's
the slider and it's strike down number
seven through four
good fastball got him looking
he's not afraid to see some pitches
around slams this one to right field
with zimmer
[Applause]
talk about contributing in the nine hole
right there seeing a pitch
a little bit elevated but not elevated
enough it was a 2-1 count to was sinker
up in the zone went right into the
barrel with two men down here's straw
struck out looking and walk here's the
o2
and the strike over the outside corner
down he goes looking on three pitches
one for two on the night a single his
last time up
oh great pitch
locked him up with a fastball in the
inside corner and that strikeout number
five two and two the count on alex
ferdugo
the pitch to him
fastball called strength three
side retired in order good inning for
squadron primal reyes who is oh for two
tonight hitless in his last 17 trips to
the plate
lying to right that's going to get down
for a base hit that's a beautiful piece
of hitting by friend milwaukee i love it
when guys try to quick pitch or do
something like that and hit her just
smokes it
one two again
and avaldi with a strikeout to end the
sixth inning he's got nine of them so
bobby bradley batting second in this
inning
bobby bradley smokes one in the left
right field for a base hit and the
indians and their fifth hit of the night
off nathan avaldi that would have made
it a 3-3 game and he hammers this one
deep left field up it's gone
and that will tie the game
second time around austin hedges
lifts it just up over that 37-foot wall
his eighth home run of the year
it's his fourth in the last 22 games and
another big one against boston yeah the
my only question was it gonna stay up
long enough and it certainly did he got
the fastball and that was middle of the
play you get the single and now the home
run and we have a new ball game but now
in the home half of the seventh in a 3-3
game
go ahead run a board for jonathan arrows
1-1
aruz is swinging and he lops it to left
field mercado's back and it's off the
wall
santana rounds third he gets a stop sign
there on a wall ball double from our
ooze
is 02. schwarmer pulls it into right
center field the base hit and that'll go
all the way to the wall
schwarber brings in two and the red sax
lead
it's an 02 pitch right there throws it
basically right down the middle after
two quality pitches misses his spot
catcher wants that up in the zone but it
just doesn't quite get there stays
around the belt buckle
nice job by schwarber driving it the
other way you want to get something deep
in the outfield with two runners in
scoring position knocks them both in
they're gonna put alex verdugo on to get
to a righty here and hunter renfro
two-two again
and renfro pulls this one
left field
and that ball is gone
how about that say what he saw enough
pitches he all he has is the fastball
and the slider hunter was fouling off
the fastballs throughout this at-bat
through a slider made that mistake we
were talking about over the dish hunter
made him pay right there well bobby got
him going last inning with a
single in the right field
there's a bloop there's a point down and
zimmer's gonna score and get you run
closer there's your blue now you need a
blast
the bloop is not dead folks
here is jose ramirez with the indians
down eight to four
there's a hard hit smash that's a fair
ball down the right field line
and that's going to get a run home
rosario in the third and the indians
aren't done yet though
with his third hit of the night his
second run batted in reyes has the
highest strikeout rate of his career
this season the o2
and he chased
that's a sword from whitlock and there's
two down the red soxers strike away the
one-two
he got him swinging
garrett winlock his nails and the red
sox win a third in a row